[Música]
con más de 700 mil casos diagnosticados
eeuu está sufriendo duramente el castigo
del sars coronavirus 2 en el momento de
preparar este vídeo tan solo en el
estado de nueva york han muerto ya casi
20.000 personas a causa de lakovic 19
una situación que tal y como ha ocurrido
en otros muchos lugares ha obligado al
gobernador del estado de nueva york
andrew cuomo a decretar el cierre de
comercios y colegios estamos en el
epicentro de la crisis
bill de blasio alcalde de nueva york-
amigos las consecuencias de este
coronavirus están alcanzando todos los
recovecos de la sociedad norteamericana
incluyendo algunos que seguro nunca se
tuvieran pasado por la cabeza por
ejemplo es evidente que este virus no
entiende de muros ni de vallas
electrificadas por eso una de las
grandes preocupaciones de muchos estados
sitúa precisamente ahora en las cárceles
y la población reclusa y no olvidéis que
estamos hablando de los eeuu y el país
con el mayor número de presos de todo el
planeta más de 2 millones de personas
están entre rejas
este panorama abre la puerta a posibles
contagios masivos motines incontrolables
o incluso la imposibilidad de contar con
el personal suficiente como para
ocuparse de estos lugares todo esto ha
hecho que 15 estados hayan establecido
duras medidas extraordinarias que
incluso prohíben el acceso de abogados a
las cárceles
y no sólo eso muchos condados están
revaluando sus políticas de detenciones
de una forma que os doy mi palabra os
puede dejar con la boca abierta
por ejemplo en baltimore una de las 25
ciudades más peligrosas de todo el mundo
no se están presentando cargos por
delitos de tenencia de venta de drogas o
por cuestiones relacionadas con el
oficio más antiguo del mundo es decir
que las autoridades van a mirar para
otro lado mientras dura la crisis
sanitaria pero no sólo eso aún hay más
no se trata solo de meter al menor
número de personas en la cárcel sino que
incluso algunos estados como un montana
están yendo mucho pero que mucho más
allá y han puesto sobre la mesa la idea
de empezar a liberar a tantos reclusos
como sea posible especialmente a todos
aquellos condenados por delitos no
violentos que ojo representan ni más ni
menos que la mitad de toda la población
presa las universidades y los hoteles
los puedes cerrar yo estoy con gente a
la que no puedo mandar a casa tom dart
sheriff del condado de cook en illinois
os lo hemos dicho el coronavirus está
llegando a todos los rincones de la
sociedad norteamericana y la marina no
es una excepción
[Música]
ni siquiera el uss ese de theodore
roosevelt uno de los todopoderosos
portaaviones nucleares de la clase
nimitz ha conseguido liberarse de la
pandemia a mediados de marzo mientras se
encontraba haciendo maniobras en el mar
del sur de china el coronavirus subió a
bordo del roosevelt ahí comenzó la
pesadilla apenas una semana después un
informe una carta del propio capitán del
portaaviones se filtró a la prensa
en ella el capitán crociere alertaba a
sus colegas y a sus superiores de la
insostenible situación por la que se
estaba
usando en el portaaviones por culpa del
sars coronavirus 2 y urgía al desembarco
lo antes posible de toda la tripulación
para frenar los contagios sin embargo la
historia no terminó bien a pesar de
contar con el apoyo de sus superiores y
de la tripulación la casablanca cesó
fulminantemente al capitán crociere del
mando del portaaviones el motivo que su
carta creaba alarmismo
el caso es que poco después dimitió el
mismísimo secretario de la marina no
estamos en guerra los marineros no
tienen que morir
brett crociere es capitán del
portaaviones uss esco2 roosevelt y de
las cárceles pasando por la marina hasta
llegar al mismísimo censo cuya
elaboración por primera vez en sus
doscientos treinta años de historia
puede estar en peligro y si vale puede
que estéis pensando pero enrique que un
pensó de qué demonios me estás hablando
pues amigos es que este nuevo es un
censo cualquiera con un coste de algo
más de 15 mil millones de dólares y si
lo has escuchado bien 15 mil millones de
dólares lo que evidentemente lo
convierte en el censo más caro del mundo
es un censo que se elabora cada 10 años
y cuyos resultados sirven para definir
toda la arquitectura política del país
hablamos por ejemplo de la distribución
de asientos en el congreso o del rey
delegados por estados en las elecciones
presidenciales el caso es que como veis
la crisis del coronarios está llegando a
todos los rincones del país pero amigos
llegados a este punto seguramente muchos
de vosotros os estaréis preguntando ante
todo este berenjenal cuál ha sido la
respuesta de la administración trump a
esta crisis hasta dónde llega realmente
el poder del presidente de los eeuu que
estados están haciendo lo mejor y cuál
es peor pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
la respuesta de donald trump amigos
amigas la posición de donald trump sobre
el coronavirus ha dado más vueltas que
un fórmula 1 en el circuito de
montecarlo
y eso hace que nos preguntemos ha estado
suficientemente preparada la casa blanca
para el impacto de esta pandemia hasta
dónde llega realmente la capacidad de la
administración federal pues ojo porque
aquí hay mucha pero que mucha confusión
veréis me explico aunque la presa
internacional el presidente de los eeuu
sea quien se lleve todas las portadas lo
cierto es que su papel y el del gobierno
federal dentro de las fronteras
estadounidenses están muy limitados
por ejemplo con carácter general los
temas comerciales son responsabilidad
del congreso y las decisiones en materia
sanitaria o ante situaciones de
emergencia recaen fundamentalmente en
los gobernadores estatales de hecho
incluso ante grandes catástrofes son los
propios gobernadores los que deben pedir
ayuda al gobierno federal si lo estiman
oportuno
vamos que por mucho que toma trap se
crea el xi jinping yanqui un presidente
que puede hacer y deshacer a su antojo
lo cierto es que la constitución le deja
muy pero que muy poquito margen hamilton
de jefferson en martes en washington the
world activamente school the
constitution
united states and the next pues set en
intuir que va a aceptar between the fair
lugar me entendés takeover mente en
exceso de fercam en tener absoluta
divisa cada presidente presidente de
territorios tórax antes del big game y
burger king george washington wizards
john wall washington de un billón
huntington presionan trump está inscrito
lugar de nadie
atentamente mentales después de ser un
expansión de la visión de expansión de
la dij el welfare fueron ti desde el
espanto del lienzo de preselección a
civil facebook wing
[Música]
entonces quiere decir todo esto que
trump tiene las manos atadas que su
administración carece de funciones no
por supuesto que no por poder puede
incluso activar la economía de guerra un
tema al que por cierto le vamos a
dedicar un vídeo entero los próximos
días así que ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros a visual politics si aún no
lo habéis hecho
[Música]
el caso es que aunque el poder del
gobierno federal es con carácter general
bastante limitado a los menos mucho más
de lo que podríamos pensar a primera
vista en la evolución de la crisis del
coronavirus y el papel de varias
agencias federales ha resultado clave
hablamos de organismos como la fema el
cdc o la acb a tres agencias dirigidas
por la administración trump que durante
esta crisis han sido un auténtico
desastre si se lo habéis escuchado bien
un auténtico desastre fijaos a comienzos
del 2020 cuando se conoció la existencia
de esta pandemia la jefe de la agencia
de medicamentos y alimentos decidió que
no se iban a autorizar la importación de
tests de ningún otro país es decir que
eeuu iba a desarrollar su propio test un
proyecto que además sería liderado
exclusivamente por el gobierno de esta
forma la fd al encomendó al crc en el
centro para el control y prevención de
enfermedades otra agencia pública el
desarrollo del test para detectar el
coronavirus al mismo tiempo ojo que
prohibía a cualquier otra institución ya
fuera privada como por ejemplo empresas
farmacéuticas o públicas como muchos
laboratorios desarrollar este test es
decir el gobierno federal
el monopolio para sí mismo pues amigos
aquí empezó el desastre desde mediados
de enero hasta el 28 de febrero el cdc
produjo 160.000 tests no suena mal
verdad puedes esperar porque de los 160
mil tan sólo se pudieron utilizar 4.000
el resto los tuvieron que tirar a la
basura porque pues porque la mayoría de
los tres arrojaban resultados
inconclusos vamos que los tests hallaban
más que una escopeta de feria al parecer
por una contaminación en los
laboratorios del cdc en atlanta una
chapuza y de las gordas después de que
tras prometiese que cualquiera puede
acceder a un test de coronavirus
pacientes y doctores siguen quejándose
de impedimentos mientras que los test
con una virus del cdc se retrasaban seis
semanas un laboratorio alemán produjo 14
millones de tests finalmente tras
semejante chapuza el cdc se rindió y el
gobierno permitió a los demás
laboratorios públicos tratar de
desarrollar sus propios proyectos además
poco después la sda también se lo
permitió a las grandes compañías
farmacéuticas como roche fueron seis
meses críticos tirados a la basura
simple y llanamente porque el gobierno
federal se quiso reservar el
protagonismo para sí mismo no sé qué
tenía de malo que otras instituciones
públicas o empresas privadas
desarrollaran sus propios test de locos
y aquí no termina todo
también tenemos el caso de la fema la
agencia federal de gestión de
emergencias que es el organismo
encargado de distribuir material
sanitario a los estados que solicitan su
ayuda bueno pues parece que este
organismo tampoco está pasando por su
mejor momento en una entrevista en la
cnn el 22 de marzo peter gaynor el
director de la fema reconoció que el
descontrol era tal que no sabían
siquiera el stock de materiales que la
agencia manejaba es decir dicho de otra
forma que no tenían ni idea de qué
capacidad tenían para enfrentarse a esta
situación y ojo que no hablamos del mes
de enero ni de febrero sino de finales
de marzo pero eso no es todo la falta de
previsión ha hecho que la fema esté
teniendo muchos problemas para comprar
suministros sanitarios han llegado tarde
y ahora los suministros escasean
i
[Música]
dibujar en specific numbers on heaven y
me asusté rocafort mente pues bien el
ingeniero networks cross
ay
[Música]
y luego tendríamos también el caso de
los aeropuertos donde los controles
brillaron por su ausencia pero ahora
bien más allá del desastroso papel de
estas agencias de la falta de prevención
en los aeropuertos y de la influencia
que pueda tener su discurso político lo
cierto es que la capacidad del gobierno
federal para actuar contra el
coronavirus es limitada y eso eso nos
lleva directamente a una pregunta clave
qué papel están jugando los estados
atentos
[Música]
eeuu de verdad
unidos
lo hemos visto la firma está teniendo
muchos problemas a la hora de comprar
suministros sanitarios pero no son los
únicos
[Música]
desde el momento en el que el
coronavirus comenzó a mostrarse como un
problema real y potencialmente muy grave
los propios estados comenzaron también
en masa a acudir a un mercado escaso de
provisiones para comprar materiales lo
que les llevó a tener que pujar unos
contra otros en una batalla desesperada
por conseguir cualquier material posible
costara lo que costara
el resultado es que en cuestión de días
los precios subieron de manera
estratosférica para nueva york las
mascarillas sanitarias de 58 céntimos
ahora cuestan 750 dólares cada una ojo
un apunte importante que los precios se
disparasen no tuvo nada que ver con la
codicia de nadie la razón básica es que
los propios compradores los estados
estaban dispuestos a pagar mucho más
para arrebatarle los suministros a otros
estados es simplemente el resultado de
la escasez pura economía
pero no nos decíamos el caso es que hoy
por hoy nueva york es el gran foco del
coronavirus dentro de los eeuu
[Música]
y curiosamente a pesar de ello la
aprobación de los neoyorquinos hacia su
gobernador el demócrata andrew cuomo
está por las nubes e incluso está siendo
proyectado por algunos medios como todo
un ejemplo de gestión de la crisis
sin embargo esperar un momento porque
como solemos decir por aquí no es oro
todo lo que reluce a mí por ejemplo se
me hace muy pero que muy difícil poner a
como como ejemplo
al gobernador neoyorquino le tembló
mucho la mano a la hora de cerrar las
escuelas de todo el estado y se resistió
durante días a decretar la orden de
funcionamiento
de hecho no sé si tuviéramos en visual
política y escoger un gobernador al que
ponerle un sobresaliente nos iríamos a
un caso mucho menos mediático pero que
merece todo nuestro reconocimiento
mike the white el gobernador de ohio es
republicano de 73 años que desoyó al
mismísimo donald trump
si puede que no ocupe grandes titulares
pero the wine fue el primer gobernador
de todo el país que sin dudarlo cerró
los colegios de todo el estado
desde el primer momento este gobernador
tomó el toro por los cuernos ante el
peligro de proliferación de la pandemia
cerro bares y restaurantes pidió las
universidades del estado que
suspendieran las clases presenciales y
se dirigió sin tapujos a los ciudadanos
que se aconsejándoles por ejemplo que
acudieran a eventos deportivos masivos
todo esto cuando en ohio apenas había
una docena de casos confirmados y 00
personas fallecidas
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea por buscar
una comparación isabel díaz ayuso la
presidenta de la comunidad de madrid'
que es una de las regiones más afectadas
de todo el mundo anunció el cierre de
los colegios el día 9 de marzo una fecha
en la que madrid acumulaba ya casi 600
casos positivos y más de una docena de
muertes los errores que he cometido a lo
largo de mi carrera han sido
generalmente porque no tuve demasiados
datos que no investigue demasiado así
que me mentalicé de que en esta ocasión
iba a tener la mejor información los
mejores datos disponibles mike de wayne
y no sólo eso cuando donald trans se
empeñó en tratarla abrir la economía
para la pascua de wayne muy
elegantemente le contestó que nos
engañará que lo primero es lo primero
cuando la gente está muriendo cuando la
gente no se siente segura la economía no
va a regresar mike de wayne pero si
tenemos al bueno creo que también
tenemos que buscar al malo amigo si
tuviéramos que tirar de las orejas a un
gobernador por su gestión durante esta
crisis
muy probablemente esa persona sería el
gobernador de florida ron de santis un
republicano y tram pista hasta la médula
a diferencia de otros gobernadores de
santis hizo oídos sordos a la
información que se venía conociendo y se
limitó a seguir a pies juntillas las
recomendaciones del presidente si
florida cerró algunas playas y algunos
parques pero mientras la mitad de los
estados ya habían decretado la orden de
quedarse en casa muchas playas de
florida seguían llenas de turistas
y si tenemos en cuenta que florida es
considerado el paraíso de los jubilados
en eeuu ya os podéis hacer una idea del
riesgo potencial que han tenido las
decisiones de este gobernador un
gobernador que finalmente el día 1 de
abril ante la evolución de los
acontecimientos se vio obligado a
decretar la orden de quedarse en casa e
imponer cuarenta y más obligatorias a
personas procedentes de otros estados
como nueva york'
vamos más lento que una tortuga con
reuma
en fin ya lo veis dos estados actuando
de forma muy diferente y es que amigos
en esta crisis en eeuu los gobernadores
son los grandes protagonistas
eso sí que quede claro la influencia de
trampa a nivel político es más que
evidente y además ya sabéis que este año
hay elecciones lo que hace que el
presidente esté muy pero que muy
nervioso y claro es que noticias así no
ayudan eeuu tiene ahora 22 millones de
desempleados aniquilando toda una década
de crecimiento laboral y aquí por cierto
es donde surge la nueva estrategia
política de la casa blanca para las
elecciones del 2020 una estrategia que a
nivel sanitario pasa por reforzar y
reforzar la idea de que china y la
organización mundial de la salud son los
grandes culpables
trump paralizar la financiación de la
organización mundial de la salud por su
manejo del coronavirus lo cual vale
puede ser cierto pero eso no exime tu
responsabilidad si te dedica este es a
mirar para otro lado no os parece y en
esta crisis el gobierno federal pues no
sé no ha hecho que digamos muchas cosas
bien
y luego pensando más allá a nivel
económico
bueno fijaos en estos mensajes liberad
michigan liberad minnesota liberad
virginia y proteged vuestra gran segunda
enmienda está bajo asedio con este
discurso lo que quiere trump es dejar
claro que si hay daños económicos es por
culpa de los gobernadores que no le
hicieron caso aunque los gobernadores de
estos estados estén actuando conforme a
lo que la experiencia internacional dice
que tienen que hacer para enfrentarse al
problema en fin cuál pensáis que será el
próximo movimiento de la administración
trump qué consecuencias tendrá toda esta
crisis para la economía de los eeuu le
costará todo esto la presidencia donald
trump muchas preguntas imposible de
responder en estos momentos como siempre
os decimos en visual política estaremos
muy pero que muy atentos y os contaremos
cómo discurren los acontecimientos pero
por ahora lo que sí podéis hacer es
dejarnos vuestras opiniones en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis darle al
botón de like una vez más muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
por cierto apunten nuestros amigos del y
jm han preparado un concurso para este
tiempo de confinamiento os dejamos en la
descripción todos los detalles
es todo
[Música]